Because God has shown that his one
desire above all things is that no one
perishes. No one is destroyed. All turn
to him and live. And he'll go the extra
mile out of his way to avoid having to
destroy anyone and will wait till the
last second before he unleashes his
wrath because he doesn't want anyone to
perish here.
So, you have a lot to learn about the
character as I do. No one knows God's
character completely by really knowing
these books and their theology before
venturing into Revelation. And if you
don't, you're not going to you're going
to confuse yourself and everyone else
that hears you. And I'm going to show
you the heart of God. You ready?
>> All right. Hold on. Just don't don't be
anxious. Once you know this is God's
heart because God is pure love and wants
everyone to save. Always keep that in
mind. God will go the extra mile. God
will do everything he can even up to the
last second
to avoid destroying anyone hoping they
turn. Watch here. This is the art of
God. For no one is cast off by the Lord
forever.
See he doesn't want to cast people off
Though he brings grief, he will show
compassion.
So great is his unfailing love. For he
does not willingly bring affliction or
grieve anyone. He doesn't want to hurt
anyone. For he does not afflict from his
heart or grieve the sons of the men. It
doesn't delight his heart. He takes no
pleasure in harming people.
M
>> that's why it breaks his heart that he
has to break yours cuz he doesn't want
to pour out his anger.
He wants to flood you in his love. It's
right here.
>> Reminds me again.
>> That reminds me of Ezekiel.
>> Oh, that's where I'm going next.
>> Oh yeah,
>> we all need him. Crystals, if you know
how much I need him because of my
wickedness here. Lamentations 33739.
Who can speak and have it happen if the
Lord has not decreed it? Nothing can
happen. No blessing, no disaster unless
God has decreed it. But why does he
decree it? Is it not from the mouth of
the most high that both calamities and
good things come? When a nation is
destroyed, uprooted, a nation prospers,
where does that come from? That comes
from God. But then why does God decree
destruction here? Why should the living
complain when punished for their sins?
You get what you deserve. You see the
point?
So why does God
why does God
bring destruction upon nations? Because
they leave him no choice. They keep
sinning. They keep blaspheing.
They keep slandering. They keep opposing
him, unborn children,
children,
oppressing the poor, taking advantage of
widows,
stealing money from the poor, you name
it. All kind of atrocities,
banning
Bible study, stopping prayer,
imprisoning Christians, killing them.
And there's only so much God can put up
with, right? And then he says, "Enough
is enough." Now I decree destruction.
But notice this is the same tap chapter
limitations 3. Same chapter earlier. He
already told you here. Same chapter.
Chapter 3. I do not
afflict from my heart. Meaning it's not
from my heart to want to hurt you.
I do not delight in grieving the sons of
men. But you leave me no choice.
So this is the God of scripture. Now,
unless you have this in the background
of your mind and know that this is the
heart of God, God goes out of his way to
tell you this is my character. I am pure
love and I want to love and I want to
bless and I want to change and transform
people. They're not going to understand.
A lot of these prophecies have within
them conditions. Not all prophecies are
conditional. Some are unconditional. But
you have to read the scriptures
carefully and astutely to know when a
prophecy is conditional and when one is
unconditional.
>> Right? You want me there?
>> Yeah.
>> But I want to show you something else
that will break your heart for God's
heart because I'm going to show you
Ezekiel. But a lot of people don't know
this in Ezekiel. So you everyone's
listening. Maria hint hint. Maria.
Maria.
This passage when I first read it
blew me away and brought me to tears.
Why?
Watch what it says here. Ezekiel 6:9.
Then those of you escape, meaning those
who went into captivity for punishment,
but then you come out of captivity among
the nations to which they will be
carried captive. How I have been broken
over their adulterous hearts. Right
here, look what God says. Which turned
away from me. Another translation. How I
have been grieved by their adulterous
hearts. Look what he said. When you
committed spiritual adultery by
worshiping the gods and gods, goddesses
of the nations. You broke my heart.
My wife Israel,
when you went after your lovers, meaning
the gods and goddesses of the nations,
cuz you were more drawn to them, you
found them more attractive than me. How
you broke my heart, smashed my heart to
smitherines.
But you will realize, you will realize
how much you hurt me, how much you
crushed my heart, and you're going to
regret it. and you're going to grieve
and turn back to me.
They will loa themselves when they
realize how much they broke my heart and
hurt me. This is God speaking.
God talking about maggots like me
breaking his heart. Why
should he be heartbroken? He doesn't
need me. Yeah, he doesn't. But it's not
about need. It's out of love. I'm going
to show you in other translations. One
second.
because I want to show you how other
translations render this.
When I first read this, I was floored.
When I first read this, I was floored,
right?
that God would speak this way,
that a maggot like me can have such an
impact on him and break his heart and
make him cry.
>> Yeah.
>> See, right?
>> A maggot like me doesn't need. But I
want to show you
because I am broken with their horish
heart. meaning they keep breaking my
heart and making me grieve, hurting my
heart because they turn away to gods and
goddesses. That's spiritual adultery
when you worship others besides God. I
just want to see how other translations
render it. I have been broken. Broken,
right? I was crushed.
How you crushed my heart?
You shattered my heart.
How I was crushed. This is God speaking.
Interesting.
How broken I have been. You made me
grieve and cry and broke my heart.
See,
>> broken because you kept cheating on me,
kept turning to other lovers, meaning
gods and god of spiritual adultery.
>> You guys remind me of Hosea now.
>> Yep. Hosea chapters 1 and 3 and also
Ezekiel chapter 23. I mean, see, I've
been there. I've I've done millions of
sessions. Go watch the session I did,
Christ and the great divorce. If you
don't start balling like a baby, they
made me very sad. Look this translation.
How I was heartbroken.
You broke my heart. Literally, that's
what God is saying.
how I was hurt, grieved, crushed.
This is the true God of the Bible. This
is the God revealed in Jesus Christ.
This is the God revealed in Jesus
Christ. The only thing we've added
before creation, father, son, spirit,
loved, adored one another, were in love
with one another, delighted one another,
caused one another to rejoice, filled
with infinite joy.
When God created creatures, we could not
improve on that love, add to that love.
The only thing we added the first time
and God's eternal existence.
God now experiences heartache,
being heartbroken, being crushed,
and being made to cry. Something he
never experienced before creatures
existed.
That's the only thing we've added to
God. Prior to creation,
God never cried. God's heart was never
hurt, was never crushed. after creation,
day in day out, we break God's heart. We
make him cry.
>> Yeah.
>> Day in day out, that's the only thing
we've added. So if you ask the Lord, why
did you create us? You didn't need us.
And his answer will always be,
>> I never created you out of need. I
didn't create you because I needed you.
I created you because I love you. That's
the answer. Here's an example. Here's
the human face of God crying,
weeping, crying, tears.
You know, before creation, God would
have no reason to cry. Before creation,
God would have no reason for his heart
to be broken and crushed and to say,
"You have broken my heart.
You have crushed my heart.
You've hurt my heart. You've hurt me.
But now watch the difference. Luke
19:41-44.
Rumble. You following me over there?
Yep. Read the Gospels posted the link.
And as he approached Jerusalem and saw
the city, he cried over it. God had
never cried before,
meaning before creatures.
He never wept. He was never crushed. He
was never disappointed. He was never
rejected. He never experienced what it
is to be hated and rejected and not
found found loving enough or beautiful
enough. Never until he created us,
saying, "If you knew in this day, even
you, the things which make for peace."
And he's heartbroken and crying because
he doesn't want to destroy them.
But they leave them no choice. But now
they have been hidden from your eyes.
For the days will come upon you when
your enemies will throw up a barricade
against you and surround you and hem you
in on every side. Cuz now I'm going to
remove my hand of protection. I won't be
there for you anymore. You don't want
me. You want to go after your lovers.
You don't want me. You're not attracted
to me. You're not in love with me. I'm
not attractive enough. I'm not lovable
enough. I'm not desirable enough.
Then I have to let you go. But once I
let you go, you can't come to me for
protection because you don't want me.
That means you don't want my protection.
You don't want me to protect your kids.
You don't want me to protect your lands.
You don't want me to protect your
economy. You don't want me to protect
your society because you don't want me.
And if you don't want me, you don't want
my protection. And that's when Satan
will bring in his hordes. witchcraft,
black magic, sorcery, Hinduism,
Buddhism, Islam, and all these wicked
immoral vices.
Abortion because you didn't want me and
you didn't want my protection.
You see what you see here? You see how
it works? For the days will come upon
you and your enemies will throw up a
barricade against you and surround you
and hem you in on every side. They will
level you to the ground and your
children within you and they will not
leave in you one stone upon another
because you did not recognize time of
presentation. You didn't want me. You
don't want my love. You don't want my
protection. Who's going to protect you
now?
Who's going to protect you now?
I was the almighty husband
who could pro protect you and preserve
you and make sure you never perish. cuz
there's no power
that could come up against you and stop
me from protecting you. I was your
almighty husband, but you didn't want
me.
So now that you don't want me, you threw
me out of your schools, America. You
threw me out of your institutions. You
threw me out of your politics. You threw
me out of your court system.
Who's going to protect you?
You understand what the point is?
Yeah.
>> If you don't want me the almighty
husband who is all powerful to save you
from anything and everything because
there's no power that come against me. I
can wipe out everything in a nancond by
my word.
That means you don't want me to protect
you. Look at your schools.
Look at your high schools.
Look at your colleges. Look at your
courts. Look at your judges. Look at
your policemen. Look at your senators,
your congressmen. Look around you.
Is this what you wanted?
Now, let me finish it before, brother. I
want you to show you. John 11:33:35.
When Jesus therefore saw
her crying, now watch. Remember what I
said. Prior to creation, God never
cried, was never hurt, was never
disappointed, never angry, never
crushed.
And yet he said,
"In spite of it all,
you are worth it." So if you ask the
Lord,
you knew, didn't you, that when you
create us, you're taking a chance. We
hurt you. Yes. Why? You're worth it.
Why? Because love says you are worth
taking a chance.
You are worth me bringing you into
being. Taking a chance with the hope
that you would love me
as I love you.
So love always takes a risk.
When Jesus therefore saw her crying and
the Jews who came with her also crying,
he was deeply moved in the spirit with
trouble.
It's Lazarus. He just told her, "I'm
going to raise Lazarus." He was not
crying for the dead. He was not crying
for Lazarus. He wasn't. He just told I'm
going to raise him. Why was he crying?
When Jesus saw mothers heartbroken for
bearing their children, fathers
heartbroken for bearing their children,
children heartbroken for bearing their
parents, spouses heartbroken for bearing
their spouses, or whatever it is, see
them heartbroken and crying,
his heart breaks and he starts crying
for you.
It's like when you see your son or child
crying because they're in pain. As a
parent, you end up crying and it breaks
your heart because you love them and
what hurts them hurts you. And that's
why Jesus is crying.
That's why he's crying. Look, when Jesus
therefore saw her crying and the Jews
who came with her also crying, he was
deeply moved in spirit with trouble and
said, "Where have you laid him?" In
other words, let's get this over with. I
can't stand to see you in pain and
crying. Get me there so I can raise him
so I can then fill you with joy and no
more suffering. They said to him, Lord,
come and see. Jesus wept.
This is God, right? This is the true
God, man. I mean, this is really God.
The God that exists, the God revealed in
Jesus, the God of the Bible. Sadly, we
have some Christians who over emphasize
certain passage of scripture to make God
look like a tyrant in a despot,
unlovable and cruel and repulsive.
Though that's not the God of the Bible.